i want to briefly look at an appearance
that radical repugnant republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
made and at a religious event i guess
it's called flashpoint live
uh marjorie taylor green showed up
with a big cross necklace just to just
to remind you how deeply spiritual she
is
and she said defiantly
president trump won the state of georgia
this is a religious event and it's just
a reminder of the um
inextricably linked
christian dominionism christian
nationalism
and trumpist ideology despite trump
personally not being a religious guy
okay so marge we got i told you about
some things i wanted to ask about but
let's get right let's dive right into
the whole election integrity issue in
georgia right what do these people need
to do about that
well you know that's a big issue
if you're
how many people are from georgia i'm
assuming everyone
i i love this by the way absolutely love
it okay so
we all know that elections are of course
serious i mean i don't know about you
guys but i know that president trump won
in the state of georgia right
standing ovation other than one guy
walking around with some kind of bucket
um
completely insane completely unhinged
and again there's nothing in principle
which makes it so that if you're
an evangelical christian dominionist
nationalist type
you have to believe that the guy who
lost actually won like you could just be
a christian dominionist and be like no
trump lost
but this movement
has blended these two things together in
a very disturbing way
next clip marjorie taylor green says aoc
has the intelligence of less than a
kindergartner they want you driving
electric vehicles ladies and gentlemen
vehicles they
worship the climate and they very much
want to and this is the entire democrat
party they want to pass the green new
deal well let me tell you
the problem with the green new deal
other than the fact aoc who has the
intelligence of less than a
kindergartner by the way
that's a big applause line for this
group
it's true i work with her i know
but anyways the green new deal the
problem with the green yo deal other
than the fact that it brings carbon down
to zero which doesn't make sense because
what are trees and plants like
this is so stupid so she's like listen
trees and plants like carbon dioxide the
trees and the plants breathe in the
carbon dioxide and they spit out the
oxygen we bring in the oxygen spit out
the carbon dioxide now this is stupid
for two it's probably stupid for ten
different reasons but as i'm sure many
of you know the issue is balance the
issue is balance we have a planet we
have a world as donald trump likes to
say and we need
the oxygen and the co2 to be in balance
the issue is we are overwhelming the
planet with co2 more than the trees and
the plants can deal with
uh conversely um when when she talks
about
listen okay you you get it it's very
stupid she's
throwing stones while in a glass house
then she calls the left godless and i
love my state i've lived here i was born
here i grew up here just like many of
you and there is no way
that we are going to hand over our home
state of georgia to the radical godless
left
what does that even mean hand over the
state i mean biden won that's what you
can't really change that now try as they
might
um
she uh marjorie taylor greene is still
talking about brad raffensberger the
secretary of state who i mean listen for
all of his faults refused to just flip
the election because trump wanted it
flipped
and then we have someone running and
this is where we're all going to have a
little trouble because i'm still having
trouble
we have another woman it's like a
trifecta everyone another woman running
for secretary of state against brad
raffensberger
[Music]
right
well you know i supported jody heiss
jody heiss is an absolute lunatic
extremist who we've talked about before
so still talking about brad
raffensberger
greene warns that stacy abrams is a
major threat coming in november she's
the democratic gubernatorial nominee i
would love for stacey abrams to be the
next governor of georgia we have a major
threat
coming in november
and and i'm going to say there's three
of them and i don't think there's enough
people talking about this right one of
them is named stacy abrams
exactly exactly
and you know what she's actually right
there is a threat coming from stacy
abrams in the sense that she threatens
to overturn republican rule in georgia
and it would be delightful
really important race to get involved in
if you're thinking well do i want to get
involved in oz versus spetterman and
pennsylvania that's a good one do i want
there's lots of important races that
could make a difference
georgia having a democratic governor
could be a huge deal in 2024 we'll have
these clips on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show back right
after this